Speaker 1: . Let's go next to Brandon from
Colorado.
Brandon, you were on the air.
Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you perfectly.
Speaker 4: Great.
So my mom is heavily invested into the anti
vaccine scene and I've sent videos all the
time and I've been watching them and clearly
there is another ground of anti VAX communities
and they do not agree on facts and they're
sort of trapped in their echo chamber.
They think what they're doing is right.
And so and I do not think that the covid conferences,
like we heard this week, are not really going
to cut it for these people who are spreading
this information.
And so I'm thinking what I would be interested
to see would be the people that they think
are lying.
So medical experts, doctors, whatever, personally
confront them to show them the evidence and
hopefully talk through with them to come to
a realization of the truth, to actually get
on the page with the facts.
And I'm wondering, do you think this would
even be possible or people are considering
this?
Could this be a valid tactic to at least engage
with this very serious part of anti vaccine
research?
Speaker 1: So first of all, I mean, on a very
practical level, there's not enough doctors
and public health experts to do one on one
confrontations with anti vaccines to convince
them to change their mind.
So so on a practical level, I think it's very
difficult.
The other thing is oftentimes when people
are presented with facts and told what you
believe is wrong, here are the facts.
It doesn't convince them.
It actually makes them further kind of plant
their feet in the sand and not move from where
they are.
What we do know is that the people that are
already in one's community.
So if Dr. Fauci shows up at your mom's house,
she'll probably be like, this guy's a liar.
I, I don't I'm not going to believe this guy.
But if your mom's doctor were who presumably
she trusts, says you need to get the vaccine,
it's really important.
I've gotten it.
My patients, I've gotten it.
That does seem to have a real impact.
So I think it's less about bringing in experts
from outside people's lives to tell them you're
wrong.
It's more about creating conversations with
the people already in your community.
So for some people, it's their pastor, which
is so disturbing.
Why when we see these pastors like Greg Locke,
who we covered earlier this week, say do not
get vaccinated to their churches, a lot of
people, if their pastor said get vaccinated,
they would do it.
Same thing goes for local physicians and that
type of thing.
So I think that there's a lot to what you're
saying in terms of people need to hear from
their local doctor, whoever people they trust,
to go and get vaccinated.
If you sit, Dr. Fauci, in front of your mom,
I don't think it convinces her.
Speaker 4: Do you think that would be sort
of the same case, because what I'm saying
is to try to confront, like the host of these
shows on that shoot or whatever who have had
their shows for so long, basically, it's sort
of the same thought as
Speaker 1: what did you say, bitch, bitch.
What what was that
Speaker 4: bitch shoot bitch.
Tumba, Rumbold.
You know, those underground YouTube.
Yeah.
I mean but I mean basically the same idea
as what if we got the biggest, you know, flat
earth personalities and.
Oh, I see
Speaker 1: what you're saying.
I you were saying so if there's some really
big anti vax person with a big audience and
they get just schooled and made to look like
idiots.
Yeah.
That could have an impact.
I don't deny that.
That's an interesting idea.
Speaker 2: OK, well, thank you all.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Brandon from Colorado,
I will call you again soon.
Let's go next.
Where are we going next?
It's just crazy what's happening.
Let's go to Jovani from Santa Clarita.
Jovani, you're on the air.
Well, no, Jovani, that's too bad.